let's move about 120 miles up the coast
now where demarco morgan is in galveston
one of the many areas under a storm
surge warning good morning demarco
good morning we're already starting to
feel harvey's outer banks right now as
we speak the wind has picked up and it
is raining and the only thing that's
keeping the gulf of mexico out of the
city of galveston is this 17-foot high
sea wall right here was built about a
hundred years ago and hasn't been topped
since hurricane ike which happened back
in 2008. now when it comes to the west
end of galveston they are not protected
by a sea wall so there has been a
voluntary evacuation in order for that
area local officials say they are
bracing for a potential six to nine foot
storm surge galveston's city manager
says that he wants everyone to play it
safe there because they're talking about
the downtown area which is pretty much
in low-lying areas like the cities of
course area there which could see severe
street flooding because of a gravity-fed
drainage system operated that means the
water from torrential rains and storm
surge cannot drain out efficiently so
the city of emergency management is
basically asking everyone to prepare for
five to seven days when it comes to food
water and supplies that's just to be on
the safe side all right demarco very
good advice